Bitte hier.
Okay, alles klar.
Hallo. Ich bin der Assistenz der Autistisation und würde gerne das Aufnahmegeschick der Medizin anführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, sehr gerne.
Bevor Sie mir über ihre Becheverten erzählen, würde ich gerne ein paar Algemeine fragen.
Bitte.
Soll ich mir eine Pause machen oder?
Alles gut. Können wir weiter machen.
Wie heißt du?
Mein Name ist Sabine Peters.
Sabine?
Ja, Sabine.
Das ist ein typisch deutscher Mädchenname. Sabine.
Peters.
Peter.
Richtig, genau.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 25. Mai 74.
Was ist am Mai?
Ja, 24.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Peters?
Ich bin 47 Jahre alt.
47 Jahre alt.
Können Sie mir bitte verraten, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ich bin 72 groß.
72?
Ja.
Und 82 kg schwer.
82 kg schwer.
Okay.
Frau Peters, was können Sie tun? Was für Sie uns?
Also, Frau Doktor, ist es so?
Ich habe hier Schmerzen.
So, da habe ich Schmerzen.
Wie Feuer?
Brand wie Feuer.
Sind die Schmerzen unter den Rippen im Oberbauch?
Hier.
Okay.
Brand wie Feuer.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Es hat gestern Abend angefangen zu...
Ich muss sagen, es hat gestern Abend angefangen.
Es ist immer...
Es hört nicht auf und das tut weh.
Das ist nicht schön.
Können Sie mir bitte die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Sind Sie stehend, drücken?
Es brennt.
Brennende Schmerzen.
Krampfertig.
Brennt.
Sind Sie immer da oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Also, ich habe das vorher immer wieder mal ein bisschen gehabt.
Aber seit gestern Abend geht das nicht mehr weg.
Geht das nicht mehr weg.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das wird eher mehr, als dass es weggeht.
Sie nehmen ständig zu, haben Sie gesagt.
Nicht ständig zu, aber ich habe das Gefühl,
dass es eher mehr wird als weniger.
Okay.
Können Sie mir bitte sagen,
wie stark Ihre Schmerzen sind auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Was bedeutet eine Skala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 Jahr leid und 10, 6 stark Schmerzen sind.
10.
10?
Okay, 10.
Haben Sie momentan also stark Schmerzen?
Ja, habe ich.
Okay. Brauchen Sie ein Schmerz mit,
Ja, das wäre nicht schlecht.
Ja, bitte.
Nein, ich habe keine Allergie.
Keine Allergie.
Keine Allergie, keine Medikamente.
Nein, keine Allergie.
Nein, keine Allergien.
Okay.
Dann ich gebe Ihnen November, okay November von über die Wene.
Wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Fühlen Sie sich noch ein bisschen besser?
Ist es schon, wie lange ist es her, dass ich das Schmerzmittel gekriegt habe?
Ja, jetzt.
Ja.
Also nur ein wenig besser.
Nur ein wenig besser.
Okay.
Wie viele sind eigentlich die M.
Die Sie schon ein bisschen besser?
Ja.
Okay.
Zahin Sie mir die Bischof.
Zahin Sie mir Bischof.
Ja.
Sind die Schmerzen langsam oder pöslich begonnen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich bin aufgewacht mit Schmerzen.
Ich hatte mich schon hingelegt.
Ich habe mich schon unwohl gefühlt, als ich in den Bett gegangen bin.
Und dann bin ich mit Schmerzen aufgewacht.
Gesternmorgen.
Gestern Abend.
Nachgestern ab...
In der Nacht haben sie mit der Schmerzen aufgewacht.
Okay.
Ich trage die Schmerzen irgendwo in die Ausgabe.
Ich weiß es nicht. Die sind so stark da.
Vielleicht ein bisschen nach oben.
Vielleicht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht ein bisschen.
Okay.
Bitte?
Nein.
Okay, ist besser geworden.
Frau Fett, ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass es eine bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schmerzen gibt?
Das weiß ich nicht. Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, das tut mir leid.
Okay.
Oder ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass etwas irrschmerzt, lindert oder verstärkt?
Das erste und zweite Mal ist es ja von selbst ganz schnell wieder weggegangen.
Und jetzt geht es nicht weg. Ich weiß es nicht.
Das erste Mal war letzte Woche, haben Sie gesagt.
Ja, genau, letzte Woche. Heute ist Montag, letzte Woche genau.
Vor vier Tagen.
Vor Nassack. Freitag hatte ich das und seit gestern Abend hört das nicht mehr auf.
Vor vier Tagen, das heißt.
Genau.
Okay. Haben Sie Schmerz mit der Langenone?
Nein, das erste, zweitmal ist es ja ganz schnell weggegangen.
Und jetzt, weil es so stark ist, bin ich ins Krankenhaus gekommen.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich habe Fragen über Ihre allgemeine Sustatt.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Sie können ja mal meinen Temperatur messen, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Sie fühlen sich nicht fieberig. Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit in letzter Zeit?
An meinem Appetit war nichts.
Jetzt ist natürlich schlecht, weil ich jetzt Schmerzen habe,
aber normalerweise, am Appetit ist gut.
Ja, Sie haben Sie in letzter Zeit abgenommen oder so genommen?
Nein, gleich.
Nein.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie Schüttefrost haben,
Nachtschweiß haben, haten.
Ja, richtig.
Schüttefrost habe ich nicht gesagt.
Haben Sie nicht?
Nein, ich habe nur gesagt, dass ich sehr stark geschwitzt habe,
als ich aufgewacht habe.
Geschwitzt? Okay.
Ich habe auch stark geschmerzt und geschwitzt.
Okay.
Was ist's denn so?
Ich habe schon gesagt, Sie haben mich erwischt.
Habe ich geschwitzt, dass ich über Perspektive gemacht habe.
Ja, ich habe schon gesagt, Sie haben mich erwischt,
dass ich so weniger verspürt habe.
Ist das nicht so drin?
Kann sein.
Ist das so drin?
Noch nicht.
Ich habe Übelkeit ein bisschen, ja.
Ist schlecht.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht, aber mir ist schlecht.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass es eine Veränderung bei Ihrem Wasserlassen oder
Stugang gibt?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Die Farbe-Konsistenz.
Also mein Stuhlgang ist...
Ich habe nicht immer jeden Tag, aber jeden zweiten Tag spätestens habe ich Stuhlgang.
Und mein Stuhlgang war normal, braun.
Okay.
Und ich hatte keinen Durchfall.
Wasserlassen ist normal, Übelkeit ist normal, Stugang ist normal.
Mir ist nichts aufgefallen.
Okay.
Frau Peters.
Was meinen Sie mit chronischen Erkrankungen?
Wie... wie...
Suckerkrankheit, Bruthochdruck.
Ja, Suckerkrankheit habe ich.
Ich habe einen... ich habe, seit meiner Kindheit Diabetes.
Ich habe einen, ich glaube Typ 1, ne?
Sehr nendlich.
Typ 1 Diabetes, ich spritze Insulin.
Und ich habe hohes Cholesterin, hat der Arzt gesagt, dann nehme ich einen Medikament.
Und zwar nehme ich... wie heißt das jetzt?
Ich glaube, Simvastatin.
Simvastatin, wie viele Niveau?
20 vielleicht.
Ich glaube 20.
Noch ein Medikament, was mit E anfängt, auch für meine Fette.
Eze mit... Eze Timit vielleicht?
Eze Timit, 10 Milligramm.
Auch für meine Blutfette.
Deine... ja, ich will nur ihre Blutfette.
Das sagt man so, ne?
Blutfette sagt man.
Das heißt Cholesterin, Triglyceride beides, ne?
Man sagt Blutfette.
Könne ich das Medikament noch einmal sagen.
Eze Timit, glaube ich, heißt das?
Eze Timit.
Okay.
10 Milligramm.
Seit... 10 Milligramm.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Blutfette, diese Hochblutfette?
Ach, das macht man Diabetologe regelmäßig, das habe ich schon seit 10 Jahren.
Seit schon, seh ich.
Wie sieht es aus mit Ihren Blutzuckerwärten?
Also die Blutzuckerwärte, mein Diabetologe ist zufrieden.
Gut.
Er hat gesagt, der Langzeitzuckerwärt ist gut eingestellt.
Langzeitzucker.
Ich habe noch ein Stück.
Genau.
Ich weiß es nicht, das war so zwischen 6 und 7.
Er hat gesagt, das ist gut.
Gut, ja.
Haben Sie Insulinumpeh oder spritzen Sie Insulinumpeh?
Ich habe ein ganz freies Schema, ein intensiviertes Insulinschema,
nennt sich das.
Ich spritze immer selber, je nachdem wie der Zucker ist.
Das klappt ganz gut.
Und dann habe ich hier noch mein Freeliebre am Arm
und darüber misse ich immer mein Zucker.
Das ist ein Blutfucker.
Das ist wie ein Knopf.
Das macht man an den Oberarm dran.
Das ist wie ein Knopf, an der unten ist eine Nadel.
Das steckt man in die Haut rein und klebt es fest.
Wie lange bleibt das dran?
14 Tage?
14 Tage lang kann man das dran lassen.
Dann muss man nicht mehr piek sein.
Man hält einfach nur noch das Gerät da drauf.
Dann zeigt dir den Zucker an.
Ich habe ein Freeliebre und darüber misse ich dann.
Wann haben Sie Ihre Zucker gemessen?
Mein Zucker?
Ja.
Ich misse den ganzen Tag.
Heute Abend, quatsch.
Am Abend habe ich es gemessen.
Heute Morgen habe ich es gesessen.
Ich habe es heute Mittag schon gemessen.
Ich misse das ganz regelmäßig.
Ich esse mit dem Essen.
Ich misse das.
Ich misse das nach dem Essen.
Ich muss nur das Gerät überhalten.
Das geht ganz schnell.
Ich würde gerne nur fragen, ob es in Ordnung ist.
Ihre letzte Wert war bei 170.
Okay, danke.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Meine Mande sind raus in meiner Kindheit.
Dann haben wir die Mande.
Ich bin mit dem Essen raus in meiner Kindheit.
Dann hatte ich einen Kaiserschnitt.
Ich habe ein Kind.
Bei meiner Geburt hatte ich einen Kaiserschnitt.
Dann bin ich ...
Das war es.
Ne, die zwei Operationen.
Vor fünf Jahren war das Kaiserschnitt.
15 Jahre.
Okay.
War die Operationen komplikationslos?
Ja, war komplikationslos.
Ja, Peters, sind bei Ihnen allergien,
die Kaiserschnitt haben,
haben Nein gesagt.
Gegen Lebensmittel oder andere,
Sie haben keine ...
Ja, doch, ich habe so eine leichte Laktose
in Toleranz.
Aber gegen Medikamente habe ich keine allergien.
Ich habe etwas dagegen,
für ihre Laktose in Toleranz, gegen ihre Laktose in Toleranz.
Nein, ich nehme nicht Laktose.
Nein, ich vermeide einfach nur Laktosehaltige Lebensmittel.
Okay.
Sind Sie forsterlich geimpft, auch gegen Corona?
Ja, ich bin geimpft und geboostert.
Gut.
Frau Peters, ich benötige ein paar Informationen
über Ihre Gewohnheiten.
Rachen Sie ...
Ja.
Wie viel Zigarette am Tag?
Zwei Packungen.
Seit 20 Jahren rachen Sie 2 Packungen am Tag.
20 Jahre?
Seit 20 Jahren.
Haben Sie Husten?
Husten?
Oder Morgenhusten?
Morgens ein bisschen Schleim,
aber ich habe nicht Husten.
Okay.
Haben Sie mal probiert,
auf das Rauch zu verzichten?
Auf das Nikotin zu verzichten?
Oder darauf zu verzichten?
Haben Sie mal probiert, darauf zu verzichten?
Irgendwann mal probiert.
Irgendwann.
Nein, ich denke auch nicht,
daran.
Okay.
Sie wissen ja, aber Sie müssen das ein bisschen nachlassen.
Reduzieren oder aufhören.
Reduzieren.
Ja, geht nicht.
Ich will nicht.
Ich möchte auch gar nicht.
Warum sollte ich?
Okay.
Darüber können wir später besprechen.
Jetzt rinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Darüber können wir später besprechen.
Oder darüber können wir später reden.
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht per person.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Drogen.
Es braucht sehr viel, aber ich nehme keine Drogen.
Glauben Sie mir vor, Doktor.
Wirklich, ich schwöre es eben.
Ich nehme keine Drogen.
Ja, okay.
Ich glaube.
Sie haben ein Kind, ein Tochter oder so?
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Eine Tochter.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Frisörin.
Frisörin? Ja.
Gibt es irgendwas an Ihrem Arbeitsplatz, das Sie belasten?
Ja, auch jedenfalls.
Material finanziell läuft es natürlich nicht so gut wegen Covid.
Mal ist es nicht geöffnet.
Wir haben schon finanziell sehr, sehr großen Probleme gehabt.
Das stresst mich natürlich extrem.
Wir sind gleichfertig.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Krankheiten,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Zum Beispiel Krebskrankheit, Blut-Toch-Druck.
Meine Mutter ist in einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Mein Onkel hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Was war es?
Unkuf.
Lebt ihr Unkuf noch?
Ihr Vater ist ja gesund.
Er ist gesund und der ist am Leben.
Hat er künische Krankheiten?
Er hat ein Glaukom und ein Blut-Toch-Druck.
Wie alt war Ihr Mutter, wenn sie gestorben ist?
Ein Herzinfarkt? 60.
Sie war rettig.
Frau Peters, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mir?
Oder wollen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich möchte einfach nur wissen, was ich habe.
Ich würde gerne Jesus' Körper untersuchen.
Dann werde ich ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen und Brust-Röntgen-Film machen.
Ein Röntgen-Film nicht, sondern ein Röntgen-Torax veranlassen.
Ich werde ein Röntgen-Torax veranlassen.
Ich werde ein Röntgen-Torax durchführen.
Ich lasse ein Röntgen-Torax durchführen.
So, so was.
Aber nicht ich mache.
Röntgen-Torax veranlassen.
Und durchführen lassen oder veranlassen?
Okay.
Sobald ich beifühle, können wir wieder Bescheid haben.
Alles klar, okay.
Ich werde ein Röntgen-Torax durchführen.
Nehmen Sie Platz, bitte.
Ich komme in 5 Minuten und werde Sie untersuchen.
Ich bin ja nicht im Wartezimmer.
Ich bin in der Notaufnahme im Bett.
Ich bleibe im Bett.
Okay.
Ich komme in 5 Minuten und werde Sie untersuchen.
Minuten, nicht Minuten.
Minuten.
Ich komme in 5 Minuten und werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Alles klar, ich warte auf die Produkte.
Okay, bis gleich.
Ich kann fragen.
Für die Dependenzielle Diagnostik möchte ich Ihnen wieder fragen.
Haben Sie einen regelmäßigen Menstruationssücklös?
Ja.
Haben Sie oft Herzklopfen, Stolpern oder Rasen nach Körperlischabilizierung oder auch in Ruhe?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, dass ich die letzten 2 Mal einmal bei der Datenarbeit,
was aufgetreten ist und das andere Mal, da habe ich gestopft.
Wie viele Minuten angedauert diese?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe mich auf die Uhr geguckt.
Das kam, dann habe ich aufgehört und habe mich hingesetzt und dann ist das langsam weggegangen.
Also ich habe nicht auf die Uhr geguckt.
10 Minuten vielleicht.
Ist Luftnot aufgetreten?
Nein, Luftnot habe ich nicht gehabt.
Sind Sie mehr abhängig davon, ob Sie stehen, sitzen oder liegen?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe es nur 2 Mal gehabt und das war ganz kurz.
Das ist ja ganz kurz und dann kam es und ging es wieder.
Vielen Dank.
Wenn Sie flach liegen, ohne Atmenot zu bekommen?
Ja, kann ich.
Ist Ihnen ein zusammenhängiges Nahrungsaufnahme und Schmerzen aufgefallen?
Nein.
Haben Sie zauber aufgetreten?
Aber ich habe Luftnot brennen.
Wir haben gesagt, Luftnot brennen, aber Luftnot brennen gibt oder nicht.
Nein, ich habe keinen Aufstoßen.
Aber ich habe Luftnot brennen, aber ich habe keinen Aufstoßen.
Was ist Pyrosis?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Was ist das für eine Erbrechung?
Erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nicht erbrochen, aber ich habe Übelkeit.
Das ist dann schön schlecht.
Ich muss die Hand an die Monitor anschließen.
Ja, natürlich.
Warum?
Ich möchte Ihre Vitalzahn überprüfen.
Okay.
Es ist so schlimm.
Wir überprüfen.
Wir kontrollieren.
Okay.
Strahlen Sie Ihre Schmerzen an den anderen Körpern Teil aus?
Das hat die Prodoktor ja auch schon gefragt.
Das strahlt nicht aus.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass das so ein bisschen ...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
So.
Okay.
Ich frage die Patienten dann immer ...
Die Patienten verstehen das nicht, wenn man denen sagt,
ist das ein lokaler Schmerz oder ist das ein Großflächig?
Ich sage dann immer, können Sie mit dem Finger drauf sagen,
wo der Schmerz ist?
Ist das ein punktueller Schmerz?
Ja, das ist genau hier.
Dann geht dann ...
Okay, sage ich, das ist nicht schlimm.
Das ist ein Großflächig.
Die Fuß verstehen wir nicht, das Wort.
Das Wort, die Fuß verstehen wir nicht.
Sag dann, ist das Großflächig so?
Zeigen Sie mal, mit der Hand drauf.
Ich sage immer, zeigen Sie mal bitte mit der Hand drauf.
Und dann machen die immer ...
Wenn die so machen ...
Und dann sage ich immer, ist das ein tiefer Schmerz
oder kann ich den Schmerz auslösen?
Dann nehme ich den Finger und mach so.
Kann ich den auslösen?
Dann sagt er, nein, kann man nicht auslösen.
Ich habe den Schmerz tief ein.
Ausatmen, kann man das auslösen?
Wird das Schmerz mehr?
Ja, jetzt wird es mehr, oder zum Beispiel.
Oder ich sage immer, Arm mal bewegen, Arm hoch, Arm runter.
Rumdrehen, so rum, so rum, mache ich immer.
Tut's weh?
Ja, jetzt tut's weh.
Und so nicht? Nein, so nicht.
Dann weiß man, dass man das auslösen kann, den Schmerz.
Also zum Auslösen, lasse ich immer einmal ein und ausatmen.
Ich drücke immer einmal drauf.
Und ich lasse die mal bewegen.
Dann kann man das auslösen.
Das wollte ich nicht.
Ja, danke schön.
Herr Schöner.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe eben gerade eine Patientin mit Verdacht
auf Newcast Infactors aufgenommen.
Kann ich die Patientin vorstellen?
Ja, ne?
Ja, danke.
Wenn der Patient an Newcast Infactors hat,
dann zeigen Sie mir mal bitte das EKG,
weil dann muss der Patient ja sofort ins Katteterlabor.
Wo ist das EKG?
Sie haben gesagt, sie haben, sie haben, nein,
sie haben kein EKG geschrieben.
Nicht bitteschön.
Ich habe jetzt gesagt, ich stelle jetzt ein Patient mit Newcast Infactors.
Newcast Infactors heißt Notfall.
Patient muss sofort ins Katteterlabor.
Wo ist das EKG?
Wo hilft der Patient?
Was für ein Infactors ist?
Vorsicht.
Und immer EKG schreiben, immer.
Werden der Verdacht besteht, dass das ein Newcast Infactors ist.
Wenn Sie die ganze Zeit den Verdacht hatten,
dass das ein Newcast Infactors ist,
dann gehört der Patient an den Monitor.
Es muss an den Monitor.
Es muss ein EKG geschrieben werden.
Und es muss sofort troponieren und herzenzulassen abgenommen werden.
Wohin kommt das mit der Medikamente?
Hat keiner allergiert?
Was braucht der?
Heperin.
Und was noch?
Es heißt Aspisol.
IV ist das aspisol heißt das.
Wenn man es IV gibt, ist es aspisol.
IV ist Aspisol.
Das ist Aspirin.
Aber man sagt nicht Aspirin,
sondern das Medikament heißt das, was man spritzt.
250 Milligramm.
Aspisolin-Teparin zu spätzen. Warum hätte ich ein Problem damit? Also ich persönlich, wenn ich so
einen Patienten habe, der sagt, ich habe Schmerzen, strahlt so ein bisschen hier oben hin aus und ich habe
dem Verdacht, es könnte ein Infarkt sein, habe ich trotzdem immer ein Problem, ich Aspisolin-Teparin
zu spätzen. Warum? Warum? Kann die Patientin glaszeitig eine Blut gucken? Ja genau, das kann
ja auch eine Gastritzis oder irgendwas Erosives, keine Ahnung, das muss man ja im Hinterkopf haben,
das weiß man ja nicht. Deswegen, um das Haus zu finden, hätten sie ein Ickagie schreiben müssen.
Ja, ich wusste. Alles klar. Und sie hätten noch was fragen müssen. Das mache ich immer. Bei jedem
Patienten, der sagt, ich habe hier Schmerzen und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das was für ein Infarkt
kann es denn sein, wenn er hier Schmerzen hat. Was für ein Infarkt? Ich konntiniere. Wenn der Patient hier Schmerzen hat,
hier. Und sie haben auch den Verdacht, es könnte eine Magenblutung sein. Was für ein Infarkt könnte
es denn sein? Hinterwand Infarkt. Ja genau, Hinterwand Infarkt. Die Hauptdiagnose,
Hauptdyspensialdosnose Hinterwand Infarkt ist Magenblutung zum Beispiel oder Ulkust,
keine Ahnung, sowas ja, muss ja nicht bluten, aber es könnte ja. Deswegen müssen wir immer
was fragen, wenn wir den Hinterkopf haben, es könnte eine Blutung sein. Was fragen wir immer?
Immer. Ich frage immer jeden Patienten, der diese Beschwerden hat, bevor ich
ausgesohnt, herrschenspülp, frage ich immer, wie ist der Stuhl, wie ist der Schwarz? Ich frage immer,
ob der Stuhl sein Schwarz ist. Haben die schwarzen Stuhl, haben die Blut im Stuhl? Haben sie
nicht gefragt? Wenn ein Patient hier einen epigastrischen Schmerzen, das sind, ich
sage es jetzt mal, das sind ja epigastrische Schmerzen, ne? Wenn der Oberbau auch Epigastrum,
wenn der Patient da Schmerzen hat und sie drücken und können die Schmerzen nicht auflösen,
ja, dann kann es ja sein wirklich, dass ein Infarkt ist. Man muss ja im EKG nicht sehen,
man muss ja im EKG nicht sehen, aber sie hat ja Risikofaktoren ganz viele. Und dann frage ich
immer, haben sie schwarzen Stuhlgang, haben sie Blut im Stuhl, und wenn er sagt, nein,
alles gut, haben sie ja gefragt, haben ja gesagt, ob es braun. Aber es ist, wenn man noch
fragt, ist der Schwarz, weil die wissen das wirklich nicht, ist der Schwarz oder ist der
braun, ne? Und ich hatte auch schon einen Patienten, der hatte eine Magendlutung
und einen Hinterwandentrag. Gibt es auch. Okay, alles klar.
Entschuldigung.
Nein, Entschuldigung. Das Problem war, was am Anfang konnte ich nicht verstehen, dass der Fall ein MI ist.
Und am Ende, das verstanden, deswegen konnte ich...
Ja, ich sage, der Oberatz versteht MI nicht.
MIOKADIM FACK.
Was wollte ich noch sagen?
Sie wollten meinen Patienten vorstellen. Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberjahrs, ich wollte Ihnen
einen Patienten mit MIOKADIM FACK vorstellen. Und ich habe gesagt, wo ist das EKG?
EKG.
Können wir nehmen, dass EKG schreibt?
Ja, schreibe ich mir jetzt mal an, dass wir das
2, 3, AVF nochmal wiederholen.
Andernextremität in Ableitung 5.
Wo? Andernextremität in Ableitung 6.
6 extremitäten Ableitung, wo?
Ableitung 2, Ableitung 3.
Okay, Andernextremität in Ableitung 2.
Was?
Ableitung 2, Ableitung 3.
Nur 2 und nur 3 sagen bitte, okay.
Ableitung 2, Ableitung 3 und?
AVF.
Nein, AVF gibt es nicht.
Was?
AVF.
Okay, wirklich ist wichtig, AVF nochmal.
An extremeten Ableitungen 2, 3 und AVF.
Ja, was ist da?
ist der Hebung. Und wo ist der Patient jetzt? Wenn der Hebungen hat? Ich habe dann...
Also, normalerweise hat man Hebungen über den Hinterwandableitungen und die
Hinterwandableitungen sind Ableitung 2, 3, AVF und wenn er da hebt, das ist ein
klassischer Hinterwand. Aber ich würde jetzt der Oberjahr ziemlich sagen, dass
der über der Hinterwandableitung hebt. Erstens, erst das Fehler kann ich KJ
geschrieben. Zweitens, Hebungen, würde ich nie sagen, weil dann gehört der Patient
sofort ins Katheterlabor. Da können sie jetzt nicht gechillt hingehen und sagen,
ach ich habe jetzt eine Mülkatinfarbe, ich stelle den jetzt mal vor. Dann sagt er,
Sie sind schon mal durchgefallen, weil das geht nicht. Sie können ja sagen, er
senkt, kann ja auch Denkungen haben. Denkungen kann er auch haben. Oder, ja, die
Hinterwandableitungen sind ein bisschen auffällig, das sind so
T-Negativierung, kann ja alles sein. Senkungen sind ja auch ein Hinweis dafür.
Kann auch ein Endstemi haben. Nicht ST-Hebungsinfarkt, muss ja nicht ein
Stemi sein. Stemi ist ja, wenn er hebt, ne? ST-Hebungsinfarkt, Stemi. Und Endstemi
ist ja, hebt nicht. Also können Sie sagen, im EKG unauffällig, kann ja auch
sein. Aber ich würde nie sagen, hebt. Weil dann müssen Sie sagen, der Patient
hat gehoben und ich habe ihm sofort ins Herzkatheterlabor gefahren und der
wird jetzt gerade katheter. Dann, top.
Alles klar. Okay.
Entschuldigung.
Okay.
Dann bin ich an das, ich habe gesagt, dass die Patientin ST-Negativierung hat.
Die Patientin ST-Negativierung hat am EKG oder auf EKG.
Im EKG. Im EKG.
Im EKG.
Mhm.
ST-Negativierung hat, sie hat, ja, seit gestern haben,
also die Patientin ST-Negativierung hat, sie hat, die die Patientin ST-Negativierung hat,
Die Schmerzen sind sehr langweilig, sie fühlen sich wie Zoltbrennen.
Sie ist sehr krass, sie fühlen sich wie Zoltbrennen.
Sie haben die Barsche, die ich für vier Tage haben,
Aber sie sind leicht verschwunden.
Sind spontan zurückgebildet oder verschwunden?
Spontan verschwunden, kann man auch sagen.
Oder haben nicht lange angehalten, kann man sagen.
Die Schmerzen haben nicht lange angehalten.
Sind spontan verschwunden oder haben spontan existiert oder sowas?
Die Schmerzen haben spontan existiert.
Die Patienten konnte keine Auslöser oder keine Verbindung mit dem Essen genannt.
Die Patientin konnte keine Verbindung mit dem Essen genannt.
Die Patienten? Ja, genau.
Die Patientin hat keine Verbindung mit dem Essen genannt.
Ihre Appetit ist normal.
Sie hat gerade Pyrosis und Wormitus,
Arbriöbelkeit, Neusea, Pyrosis und Neusea.
Es gibt keine Auffälligkeiten bei
Sturgank und Urin.
Bei der Patientin, seitdem die Verbindung ist, ich konnte sie nicht hören.
Alles gut, alles gut.
War nicht wichtig.
Die Patientin hat Diabetes me.1 seit ihrer Kindheit.
Sie schiebt Risuline.
Sie hat Auserden, Dislipidemia und sie nimmt dagegen
20 mg und es setmet seit 10 mg Senioren.
Sie hat Tonzyllectomy und Kaiserschnitt,
Vorfünfteejahr, die Operationen waren kopifikationslos.
Die Patientin hat leichter Laktosintoleranz.
Deswegen kann man diese Laktoshaltige ernehren.
Die Patientin hat eine Nahrungsmittel.
Die Patientin hat 2 Packungen seit 20 Jahren.
Sie hat keinen Kontakt mit den Drogen.
Sie hat keine Alkohol.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat eine Tochter.
Sie ist Frisurin vom Beruf und hat finanzielle Probleme.
Ihre Mutter ist mit 60 am Myokartinfarkt gestorben.
Nicht mit Myokartinfarkt, nicht mit Myokartinfarkt.
Am Myokartinfarkt gestorben.
Sie hat Loko und Arterial-Hipartoni.
Anhand an amnestischen Anwesenden vermute ich,
dass ich bei der Patientin ein Myokartinfarkt dafür schmerz.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass die Patientin, weil die Patientin Diabetes-Militus-Tip 1 hat,
ihre Schmerzen sind.
Die Diabetes-Militus-Tip 1 hat stummtum Schmerzen.
Diabetes in Europa hat sie.
Sie hat keine richtige Schmerz.
Sie hat ganz starke Schmerzen.
Ich würde sagen, dass als Risikofaktoren Diabetes-Militus,
Zigaretenkonsum und Hyperlipidemie die Rolle ist.
Stummarinfarkt bedeutet, sie hat keine Schmerzen.
Wenn sie Schmerzen hat, kann das kein Stummarinfarkt sein.
Auch wenn sie ein Typ 1 Diabetes hat, hat Schmerzen.
Polyneuropathie kann nicht sein, weil sie hat ja starke Schmerzen.
Auch wenn sie Diabetes-Karin ist.
Aber sie hat ein sehr hohes, kardiorwaschuläres Risikoprofil.
Sie hat viele risikofaktoren.
Langjähriger, langjähriger, langjähriger, insulinpflichtiger Diabetes-Militus.
Langjähriger, insulinpflichtiger Diabetes-Militus ist ein großer Risikofaktor.
Dann hoher Nikotinkonsum, starker Nikotinkonsum.
Wie viel? 40 Päck hier.
Sie ist erst 47 Jahre alt.
40 Päck hier ist Nikotin, langjähriger, insulinpflichtiger Diabetes-Militus
und familiäre Disposition, familiäre Belastung.
Die Mutter ist am Infarkt gestorben, und zwar mit 60, nicht mit 80.
Das zählt noch als Jugend, gell?
Die Mutter, und das ist schon ein sehr hohes kardiorwaschuläres Risikoprofil.
Plus habe ich gesagt, dass sie hohes Cholesterin hat,
und ich habe es betont, weil ich gesagt habe noch, sie nimmt Medikamente ein.
Das heißt, es muss hoch sein, dass der Arzt ihr mit 47 noch Medikamente gegeben hat.
Muss sie ja auch haben, wenn sie Diabetes und so was.
Sie ist ja ein Hochrisikopatient.
Deswegen braucht sie das auch.
Das heißt also vier ganz große Risikofaktoren.
Allein dieses kardiorwaschuläres Risikoprofil, auch wenn das EKG unauffällig ist
und diese Schmerzen, die nicht aufhören,
sollten einem dazu verleiten, dass es auch in der Hinterwand Ichhämie sein kann.
Muss ja nicht in Stämie sein.
Es kann ja auch in Entstämie sein.
Was muss man dann abwachsen?
Was muss man dann ganz schnell haben?
Wir haben gesagt, da ist nichts. Was muss man dann noch haben?
Wir müssen uns auch nicht aufhören,
um den Kardiakentzimmer zu beachten.
Nicht Kardiakentzimmer,
sondern Herzenentzimmer zu beachten.
Welche?
Troponin.
Troponin ist kein Entzimmer.
Troponin ist ein Protein.
Troponin und CK und CKMB, die drei.
Aber Troponin ist kein Enzym.
Troponin müssen wir machen und die Enzyme CK und CKMB müssen wir machen.
Und wenn er jetzt ein hohes Troponin hat, sie und CK ist normal.
Hat sie dann keinen Infarkt?
Nein, wir können das nicht sagen.
Vielleicht ist es Fensterperiode.
Nein, Troponin reicht es aus.
Wenn das Troponin erhöht, ist das ein Infarkt.
CK muss nicht positiv sein.
Es ist ein kleiner Infarkt.
Wenn CK noch mal ein größerer Infarkt,
aber Troponin erhöht, ist es ein Infarkt.
Das wollte ich noch sagen.
Was zieht man im EKG bei ihr?
Wo sind die Hebungen?
Wo müssten die EKG-Veränderungen bei ihr sein?
Wo müssten die Epidemiöse bei ihr sein?
Wenn es schwerfällt,
die extremitäten Ableitungen zu sagen,
dann sagst du einfach,
in den Ableitungen
Nein, nicht eins.
Wo sind die Ableitungen?
Wo sind die Pathologen bei ihr?
Zwei.
Ableitungen zwei und drei?
Ja, und?
Ja, ist egal.
Es ist ja keine Erkenntnisprüfung.
Aber warum?
Weil wir von einem Hinterwandgeschehen ausgehen.
Hinterwand tut da immer weh.
Können wir jetzt noch machen?
Wenn es nicht so schnell geht,
dann muss es in den EKG.
dann warten wir den Labor ab.
Was können wir noch machen, bis der Labor da ist?
Wir haben doch schon gesagt.
Echokardiografie.
Das sieht man ja auch schon ein bisschen was.
Wandbewegungsstörungen,
ein gescheinende Kumpffunktion vom Herzen.
Sehr gut.
Aber es könnte ja auch etwas ein Ulkus sein.
Woher wissen Sie, dass es kein Ulkus ist?
Ohne Gastroskopie können ich nicht.
Sie herrscheinen das S-Wutkuss.
Genau, das wissen wir nicht.
Aber wir würden trotzdem erst mal,
wenn sie keine Blutung hat,
wenn sie keinen Druckschmerz hat,
wenn man drauf drückt,
wenn es nicht nahrungsabhängig ist.
Bei dem kardiovaskulären Risikoprofil
liegt es ja nahe, dass es eine KHK ist.
Das wiederholen Sie jetzt mal, was ich jetzt gesagt habe.
Warum denken Sie,
dass es eher vom Herzen kommt und nicht vom Malen?
Weil die Patienten...
Weil die Patienten
keine Druckschmerz...
keine Druckschmerz an den Magen hat.
Im Epigastrium, nicht Magen, im Epigastrium.
Keine Druckschmerz im Epigastrium.
Keine Blutung...
Eine Blutung? Nein, das können Sie nicht sagen.
Keine Blutungszeichen können Sie sagen,
aber keine Blutung dürfen Sie nicht sagen.
Keine Blutungszeichen, denn was sind Blutungszeichen?
Was?
Was sind Blutungszeichen?
Tärstuhl, Blut im Stuhl. Erst mal.
Keine Blutungszeichen, das sind die Zeichen.
Die man sieht.
Fakuskopisch.
Wiederholen, nochmal.
Warum denken Sie, dass es vom Herzen kommt?
Weil Sie keine Blutungszeichen haben.
Und keinen Druckschmerz im Epigastrium-Bereich haben.
Und? Warum noch?
Und warum?
Und weil Sie ein sehr hohes, kardiovaskuläres Risikoprofil haben.
Was für ein Herz ich mir stimmt.
Sprech, steh ich davon aus,
dass es ein KKK ist.
Nochmal alles von vorne, wiederholen.
Weil die Patienten keine Blutungszeichen haben.
Keine Blutungszeichen, was meinen Sie mit Blutungszeichen?
Keine Blutungszeichen, ich meine,
keine Tärstuhl oder...
Oder aber auch...
Hämatöme.
Super.
Und was noch?
Warum glauben Sie noch?
Sie hat auch kein Risikoprofil.
Und was noch?
Und den Schmerzen sind nicht nach uns abhängig.
Und die Schmerzen sind nicht nach uns abhängig.
Und Sie hat auch ein Risikoprofil.
Zum Kardiovaskrankheit.
Kardiovaskuläres Risikoprofil.
Ich will Sie nicht wieder hören.
Kardiac gibt es im Deutschen nicht.
Corona-Herstrankheit.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ein Risikoprofil auf Corona-Herstrankheit.
Deswegen gehe ich davon aus, dass die Patienten...
Sehr gut.
Super.
Mucatinfarkt hat.
Mucatinfarkt oder Zustutungsstörung am Herzen hat.
Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Aber sehr gut.
Super.
Ich war ein bisschen streng, aber das ist wirklich wichtig.
Wenn man die Herzkartier-Untersuchung gemacht hat,
nehmen wir mal an, haben wir oft.
Alles ist typisch.
Horskartiovaskuläres Risikoprofil.
Und dann machen wir Herzkartier-Untersuchung.
Alles unaufregend.
Das machen wir dann.
Dann machen wir eine Marmenspiegelung noch, bevor wir den Patienten nach Hause schicken.
Okay?
Alles klar.
Wenn der Patient, jetzt kommt noch was anderes.
Das ist jetzt schwierig.
Wenn der Patient Tärstuhl hat.
Und der HB ist bei 9.
Und er war vor einem Monat im Krankenhaus.
Da war der HB 14.
Jetzt ist der HB 9.
Er hat Tärstuhl.
Und hat auch ganz stark EKG-Veränderungen.
Was machen Sie zuerst? Herzkartier-Untersuchung oder Marmenspiegelung?
Ich sehnt davon ab, ob die Herz-Enzymen erhöht sind.
Ne.
Da muss man den erst mal spiegelen.
Wenn man Herzkartier macht und der ist hochpathologisch,
dann muss man Blutverdünnung geben.
Deswegen muss man erst mal ein Spiegelung klippen.
Und dann die Trübbelleit noch fragen.
Klar.
Ich wollte was sagen.
Die Anamnese war super.
Deutsch ist super.
Ausdrucksweise, das sprechen, Anamnese.
Super.
Aber Sie müssen ein bisschen mehr bei der Differenzialdiagnose
und Untersuchung noch mal.
Also, wo tut es weh, wenn ich drauf drücke, tut es weh.
Und die Tärstuhl oder so was.
Ein bisschen so was mehr fragen.
Aber sonst war alles gut.
Ja, danke schön.
Es war sehr gut.
Es war wirklich okay.